AGV: Today we're talking about
machine learning and contact
centers, Workflows, and N2 VMs.
I'm AGV, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Speaker ID brings Google's
speech identification
technology directly to Google
Cloud customers and our contact
center partners.
Instead of subjugating
callers to tedious
and circuitous authentication
processes, such as phone trees
or menus with speaker IDs,
our customers and partners
can now initiate service using
the most intuitive interface
of all--
voice.
With Workflows,
developers can easily
orchestrate various
services together
on Google Cloud or
third-party APIs.
And with callbacks, the
execution of a Workflow
can wait until it receives a
call to a specific callback
endpoint.
Check out the blog
for examples and how
to use the helpful new feature.
We are also expanding our N2 VM
family machine-type offering,
which will now offer our largest
Intel-based, general purpose,
pre-defined machines to date.
For scale-up workloads, that
can benefit from a higher number
of threads.
We are also increasing the N2
custom machine-types maximum,
offering a compelling
upgrade path
from first-generation
general purpose N1 machines.
Check out the blog
to learn more.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list, we
have several lovely links.
And optionally, if you would
like to leave us a comment
or tweet us, please do.
We'll see you in the Cloud.